what is it about British humor that's
better than ours is coming to town this
film tells the tale of a young guy who's
living up in the north pole got all the
elves up there and everything and it's
the night before Christmas and all the
elves are out there and they're trying
to deliver all these little presents and
everything it was like a Mission
Impossible kind of thing the elves were
dropping in on using computers and GPS
and lo and behold they misplace one
present one present is not delivered as
expected this one little kid his name's
Arthur he's the guy who handles all the
letters that are sent to the North Pole
he decides to go out and try to deliver
this little bicycle to this girl before
she wakes up and it's this big humongous
adventure filled with lots of British
humor and clever things
going down the chimney never did Manny
this is an extremely clever children's
film I've seen a lot of children's films
this year and a lot of them have been
really disappointing Happy Feet two cars
- this is the kind of movie where when I
was watching and I was like I can see a
family watching this I can see a dad
enjoying this I can see a mom enjoying
this I can see the little kids enjoying
this I can see the teenagers enjoying
this it has a lot of hilarious humor a
lot of clever things things that
honestly some kids very young kids might
not pick up on but that is why this film
is good because it doesn't speak to one
specific demographic or talk down to one
specific demographic it is cherishable
for all demographics Steve's the brains
divides up time to 14 1 1 3 seconds my
love and espresso and then there's
Arthur I just want it to be perfect for
every kid it's extremely funny the
animation is really really good in this
film I was actually extremely surprised
and how much I enjoyed this film there's
a lot of really good arguments between
characters in this movie see it's all
one big family up there
Arthur kind of wants to just make this
girl happy his older brother wants all
the glory for himself and then the
father of course once all the glory for
himself because he's Santa and you know
that's just you know he's a fat old guy
and he doesn't understand what's going
on actually there's been a glitch yeah
there's one small problem
single file
the film has extremely good CGI in a
really good score actually I was just I
was very surprised at how funny this
movie was I don't want to like gush a
lot but this movie really actually made
me laugh quite a bit there are certain
aspects of winter that I hate but then
there are certain aspects of winter that
make me feel really cozy and I just want
to get by the fireplace or something and
drink some hot cocoa or something this
is that kind of movie or you just feel
like wintertime is coming and it might
not be awful you're coming to
led me on that up there old boy there -
ah dog sir what are the others colder
could never ruddy remember but but Bambi
I'm not really good with big animals I
don't have too many issues with this
film there are a few jokes that fell
flat but not really that minis clever
British humour it's fun the little elves
in the movie are absolutely adorable the
main little elf the little girl who's
there she's like the master rapper of
gifts she was awesome this is the kind
of movie that made me feel it kind of
like a little boy again I was just like
who adventure and fun and it was just a
good film so I'm going to give the film
an A - Christmas fine fine
if you like this review you can
subscribe to my channel and get step 9